bird box may have terrified you with its
chilling post-apocalyptic setting but it
was originally going to be even darker
yippee-ki-yay lovers I'm John and in
this video I'm revealing the horrific
alternate ending for bird box as well as
another terrifying river scene you never
got to see plus a deleted scene that
actually showed the creatures on screen
spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet at the end of
Byrd box Malorie boy and girl survive
the rapids despite being capsized but
then end up separated in the woods were
there tempted by the creatures to remove
their blindfolds terrorized and chased
by the monsters they flee towards the
school for the blind where they
eventually find safety in the original
script however as the monsters chase
them through the trees boy and girl make
it to the door but Mallory trips and
gets left behind
boy and girl get taken and safely by
Rick but Mallory who's stranded is
flipped over by one of the creatures the
creatures shadows fall over her face and
Mallory fights back telling the
malevolent forces to stay away she pulls
out her knife then in a horrifying
moment puts the knife's tip right next
to her eyelid warning the creatures that
shall make sure she can't look at them
the creatures buzz around her and in a
close-up shot
Mallory pricks her eye with a knife
drawing a drop of blood seeing this the
creatures all moved back and she's
finally able to get inside the building
this horrific moment would have tipped
its hat to the end of Josh malla man's
book on which the movies based and which
is also much darker spoiler for the
novel now in the books ending after
Mallory arrives at school for the blind
she discovers that many of the residents
of gouge out their own eyes so they
can't be tempted by the monsters in the
novel Rick tells Mallory that previously
the school security was much weaker and
a creature managed to break into the
building during the attack many people
died and a mother killed four children
in a fit of rage the community decided
they couldn't risk it happening again
so they blinded themselves with various
implements including forks kitchen
knives and even their own fingers the
original screenplay has a similar scene
that happens earlier but was cut from
the final film where one night Mallory
almost blinds her son
liberally with a hypodermic needle the
scene takes place at night a Mallory is
terrified as she can hear the wind or
creatures bumping against the house the
two children are asleep covered with
blankets but Mallory has reached the
point where she's decided that blinding
them as the only hope for their survival
Mallory places a needle right up close
to boy's eye but can't go through with
it after girl wakes up startled bird box
director Susana beer has said in an
interview with polygon that when she
decided to make a movie about the
apocalypse it was important to her that
there be a hopeful ending BIA says she
didn't want the audience to leave with a
completely bleak point of view and so it
was key that this scary dystopian story
has a hopeful undercurrent certainly a
version of bird box with Mallory almost
gouging out her own eyes very nearly
blinding her son on purpose or
discovering a community of people who've
clawed out their eyes as the only remedy
against the monsters is much bleaker
even if her family does still survive
indeed speaking to The Hollywood
Reporter beer also said that she cannot
do horror and is much more interested in
suspense and thrillers preferring things
that are threatening but not gory which
seems to be why some of the more gory
elements of the story have been toned
down unlike many horror or monster
movies bird box decides not to show us
what the creatures look like beyond
shadows passing over surfaces and how
the wind blows and leaves swirl when
they move however there was a moment in
the original script which was also
filmed where Mallory has a nightmare
about seeing one of the creatures the
script describes the scene where Mallory
is making a phone call and a creature
creeps up behind her she hears it and
shuts her eyes trying to hide but the
monster stretches out to ragged fingers
with wet black talons on the ends which
press against her cheek and eyebrows
similar to the final film where Geary
forces Cheryl to look in the deleted
scene the creature forces Mallory's eyes
open and she sees a wide mouthed pale
wet face with bulging eyes like a deep
sea monster
Mallory then wakes up petrified from her
nightmare and goes downstairs for some
water in the script this is the moment
when Gary arrives at the house and it's
Mallory not Olympia who lets him in in
an interview with Bloody Disgusting
screenwriter Eric highs
says he only added the nightmare scene
with the creature because there was a
time when one of the producers said you
have to see something at some point
director Susana bier said that they
actually spent a lot of time filming the
scene but what happened was that when
they reviewed the footage it just ended
up being funny rather than scary which
of course was the opposite of what they
wanted Sandra Bullock has described the
look of the creature in the deleted
footage as snake-like and resembling a
long fat baby now some people might like
to have seen a creature to get an idea
of what they looked like
but leaving something unseen into the
imagination can often be very scary and
effective especially when compared to a
poorly done CGI monster in comparison a
quiet place only showed bits of its
creatures which worked fantastically
well to create a real sense of dread
also if they had kept the deleted
monster scene in bird box it would have
made it extra obvious that Gary was
going to be in league with the creatures
and on top of that you would also likely
have worked out pretty quickly that the
creature was just a nightmare as you
know the filmmakers would be rather
unlikely to kill off the lead Firoz also
said that the idea of the creatures and
bird boxes that they tap into your
deepest fear but as everyone's fears are
different if you give the monsters a
definitive form in the movie it might
take away from that concept in the end
we still have Gary's sketches as
examples of what the creatures might
look like the original script for bird
box also reveals other deleted scenes
that were rather dark a particularly
interesting and terrifying one is an
alternate version of the final river
scene in the final movie just before
Malory and the children reach the rapids
Mallory's faced with the dilemma of
asking one of the kids to look so that
she can safely navigate the river at
that point she realizes eventually that
it's an impossible choice and instead
decides to do everything so that they
can all survive in the original script
though we get a horrific scene at this
point that feels inspired by Hitchcock's
classic film the birds as Mallory and
the children float down the river and
Mallory tries to figure out what to do a
flock of migrating birds pass overhead
squawking normally but as they approach
the rapids the sound from the birds
becomes more aggressive and they start
attacking each other dead birds begin
falling into the river and their blood
lashes onto Mallory's face a bird then
comes crashing into the boat as it tries
to kill itself the boat hits a rock and
the budgies inside the box start
chirping Mallory hears the sound of a
monster nearby and grabbing an oar pokes
it in the direction of the creature
which retaliates by capsizing the boat
this scene would have replaced a scene
with the rapids that caused the boat to
capsize in the final movie and it would
also have skipped over Mallory having to
decide which child would face the mortal
danger of being the lookout like the
alternate ending a suicidal bird attack
would have been a rather shocking scene
so I can see why this wasn't included if
the director wanted to tone down some of
the stories darkness and showing Mallory
deciding to save both children adds a
touch more optimism to the final movie
so do you wish any of these deleted
scenes have been in the movie and
watching your theories about the
monsters in Byrd box let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this smash
that subscribe button a notification
bell so you don't miss any of my new
videos
next up tapleft for more horror movie
deleted scenes or tap right for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
[Music]